foreign
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn Ryan Nicodemus is
on vacation this week but don't worry
he'll be back next week in the meantime
we've got malabama here hi everybody TK
Coleman what it is oh we got the rest of
our team here in the studio as well and
coming up today on this free public
minimal episode we're talking to a
couple listeners about topics that
seemingly have nothing to do with
minimalism we're calling this one not
minimalism although you might find that
they have a lot to do with minimalism we
also have an outstanding lightning round
segment a live stream question and a
listener tip for you you can check out
the full two and a half hour maximal
edition of episode 386 where we answer
four times the questions and we dive
deep into several simple living segments
that private podcast episode is out
right now at patreon.com the minimalists
your support keeps our podcast and both
of our YouTube channels one 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck we'll get to our
callers in a moment so if you have a
question or comment for our show give us
a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcasts that love animalists.com but
first we have a question from Erica on
patreon
what does minimalism have to do with
normal everyday subjects like
friendships having pets and enjoying
entertainment
so TK we both know that focusing on less
creates room for more
and Erica brings up friendships I was a
friendship hoarder at one one part
entire one time in my life I was a
friendship hoarder I wanted more friends
more is better and I think that is sort
of the the disease of more more stuff
must be better more square foot it has
more square footage of my home must be
better more friends must be better more
money must be better and there's nothing
wrong with any of those things but when
we're just pursuing more for the sake of
more it tends to become clutter over
time and so she mentioned a few things
here friendships for some people like
Ryan who's not here today but he is a
extrovert an extreme extrovert and so he
makes do with more friendships than me
but even then having the appropriate
amount of intentional relationships is
thriving for him with me it's having far
fewer friendships but having friendships
that are really meaningful for me but
also redefining what friendship looks
like but then there are these other
areas as well having pets we did an
entire pet episode before TK came on
board we brought some experts in here
and we talked about minimalist pets
we'll put a link to that episode in the
show notes because the truth is that you
could hoard pets in fact we see it on
the TV show hoarders right what happens
is there's well they're dead pets they
hold on to there's excrement all over
the house because when we just want more
more more the things begin to get in the
way including our pets and pet waste and
then she also mentioned enjoying
entertainment now we have this
entertainment machine in our pockets now
that a lot that follows us around
everywhere and it's easy to be pacified
to be entertained 24 7. when I'm
constantly looking for more dopamine
through my entertainment I'm not being
intentional and after a while if I binge
watch something for four or five ten
episodes I start to feel miserable in a
way yeah and so I've been thinking about
this episode I wanted to call it not
minimalism because we put a call out to
our patreon supporters and also call out
on social media and said hey we have a
challenge for you because last week we
did a whole episode about monogamy and
non-monogamy right and I'm going to talk
to you on the private podcast about how
that completely changed my mind about
some things but I also thought that
minimalism definitely has something to
do with relationships however there are
some things that probably have nothing
to do with minimalism and as we put a
call out to our patrons and said hey let
us know if you can think of something
that has absolutely nothing to do with
minimalism we're going to talk about
some of those things today I wanted to
throw a few out to you though okay and
you tell me does minimalism have
anything to do with this I'm going to
say yes already before hearing the
things because my understanding of
minimalism is such that it has something
to bring to every discussion regardless
of what it is okay so tell me about this
I've gone down this Rabbit Hole recently
of the Egyptian pyramids and it seems
that the Egyptians didn't actually build
these pyramids 4500 years ago at least
there's a lot of evidence to the
contrary there and I looked at that and
I said well what the hell does
minimalism have to do with that TK so
let's back up a little bit because I
believe you gave earlier the defining
question of minimalism which is how
might my life be better with less now
what's interesting is whenever we say
that the most common question we get in
response to it is well what about people
who don't have enough as it is and I
think that question comes because
there's a silent phrase that gets
attached to the end of your question and
that phrase is physical Goods so when
people hear how might my life be better
with less what they hear is how might my
life be better with less physical goods
and I just like the question as it is
with the less because that leaves room
for other kinds of baggage there there's
physical clutter but we also carry
philosophical baggage and we also carry
psychological baggage which we bring to
bear on all of our experiences right so
I would Define philosophical baggage as
any self-defeating belief or any element
of incongruence in your world view and
psychological baggage I would Define
that as maybe an ineffective or harmful
way of processing your emotions or or a
self-defeating pattern of Behavior now
consider any issue in your life ask
yourself if that issue is less than
perfect in your life
is there an opportunity for improvement
by taking a look at the philosophical
assumptions you're making taking a look
at the patterns of behavior you have
around it taking a look at the way
you're processing your fillings in
relation to that issue and doing some
unpacking doing some simplifying usually
every approach to problem solving
involves some element of that and so
minimalism may not be let's say a
political philosophy or a sociological
Theory it may not be a comprehensive
theory of pets right or it may not be a
philosophy of money or race but there
are mental models and strategies that
are employed in the minimalistic
worldview that can be applied to
anything because it's impossible to
experience a clutter plot Problem
without experiencing some kind of
philosophical or psychological issue in
relation to the things that we call
clutter so that's kind of like the
groundwork now what's the particular
thing you want to want me to apply that
to well I'm thinking about a few things
here and so a few things I want to talk
about throughout the episode so we in
fact we have a question about
anti-racism that we're going to talk
about on the private podcast I'm going
to take the anti-stance you'll take the
pro-racism stance and we'll figure it
out together
um or oh the pyramids that's what we're
going to get there but but becoming an
organ donor as well we have a question
about that and
I can certainly see how minimalism
applies to that the anti-racism thing
I'm not really sure and so we'll have a
conversation about that but something
like the pyramids which for me is a bit
of entertainment I'm fascinated by it
right I'm fascinated by okay what were
the Pyramids actually used for and how
could they have possibly built those but
I don't know how to see that even
through a minimalist lens I never even
thought about it that way absolutely so
the kinds of questions you're asking
about the pyramids belong to a field of
philosophy known as epistemology it's a
much too fancy word for a theory of
knowledge uh epistemy uh the is a word
that means to know and your epistemology
refers to the theory you have about what
it means to know something what kind of
relationship must exist between our
beliefs in order for those beliefs to be
justified what it means to be rational
so anytime we criticize someone and say
well you're being irrational or you're
not being reasonable we're making
epistemic presuppositions right we are
we are revealing an epistemology that we
have a theory about what it means to
know things so when you're watching this
documentary or you're reading this book
on pyramids and you're contrasting it
with things that you have been taught
and you're starting to question those
things you're starting to do some
epistemology and what does that mean to
do epistemology what it means is that
you're starting to unearth your
assumptions right you're starting to
unpack the beliefs that you've had about
what makes a claim reliable what
constitutes an expert when should we
trust the experts and defer to them and
when should we challenge them and demand
that they demonstrate what they know in
an independently verifiable way
also what are the implications of my
beliefs about pyramids does it even
matter what I believe do we even need to
know whenever we have philosophical
discussions about anything important
like history religion the pursuit of
meaning you know our place in the
universe all kinds of epistemological
things come up and they kind of get in
the way of us being able to think
critically about these things so for
instance something that you'll often see
whenever two people are discussing
something that's complex is there's
almost always an observer of the
conversation who feels like if something
were important or true the answer would
be obvious and easy to discover and the
Very fact that we need to have these
difficult discussions where we have to
Define our terms and engage in this
complicated reasoning should be taken as
evidence in and of itself that this is
either unimportant or unknowable but
that's an epistemic assumption that's
capable of being questioned maybe it's
true maybe it's false so this is an
example of how a minimalist approach can
even help you get underneath the hood of
the presuppositions that you're bringing
in to a discussion about something like
pyramids in our last Netflix film which
you were in you or we talked about the
definition of minimalism and as this is
our definition someone else can call
minimalism something else as well but
minimalism is the thing that helps us
get past the things so we can make room
for life's most important things and so
the key there is important things and
understanding when you're talking about
the epistemology here and you're
applying it to to pyramids yeah how are
these important to me and how would this
discovery how would knowing this be
important to me it could very well be
that it's not important at all and then
I can dismiss it right but if it is
important in some way and it could be
important just because it's entertaining
I'm fascinated by it or I'm compelled by
it for a short duration of time and
that's okay as well but it's important
only if it's compelling to me now if I
go to you and say TK I need you to I you
have to read this book about the
pyramids right you must watch this video
yeah now I'm prescribing something that
may not be important to you at all
speaking of prescriptions I think
there's one other area that often is
confusing for folks when people talk
about how might your life be better with
less they append it with physical Goods
material possessions right as you said
and so then therefore we conflate
minimalism with organizing or Marie
condos tidying up yeah but I would say
that tidying up I'm not gonna say it has
nothing to do with minimalism but it has
way less to do with minimalism than how
we think because when we're thinking
we're thinking about all of these other
types of clutter right that's what I'm
going to talk to you about today it's
yes there is philosophical or mental
clutter emotional clutter spiritual
clutter calendar clutter we just did an
episode about food clutter and it has
nothing to do with the material
possessions yeah we can start with the
things but quite often the problem is
organizing or tidying up we did a whole
thing with uh Marie condo recently she
admitted that like now that I have three
kids the tidying up thing doesn't really
work that well for me yeah and what I
realized when I first stumbled into
minimalism yeah it worked for people who
were young single people traveling the
world but it also worked for people like
Leo babalta and his wife who have six
kids together in a blended family and
they are a minimalist family when I
realized oh you're setting up some
boundaries in your life and those
boundaries are much more adjustable than
just the prescriptions the rules of
tidying up Erica I'd love to send you a
copy of our actually it's free you can
download it for free it's the minimalist
rule book 16 rules for a living with
less but we tricked you it's not there
are no rules there they're just
boundaries and they're adjustable
boundaries for simplifying your life and
living more intentionally 16 different
ways to live more intentionally you can
download it for free over at the
minimalists.com
rulebook or you can find on our
resources page over at the
minimalists.com and what else let us
know in the comments is there anything
that you think has nothing to do with
the minimalism let's start a discussion
there in the comments sorry uh I want to
make one uh quick little case without
getting in the weeds why it could be
deemed as important to wrestle with
issues like who created the pyramids or
other seemingly unanswerable questions
like what is the nature of time do
aliens exist and things of that sort
if we spend all of our time only
focusing on day-to-day issues that
pertain to our survival we limited we
limit the capacity for our imagination
and we limit the development of our
critical thinking skills it's only when
we exercise our minds by wrestling with
things for which there are no easy
answers that we develop our full
potential so think about it in terms of
sports like how do you practice in
sports what's the definition of practice
well you subject yourself to constraints
and challenges that are more difficult
than what's required of you in the
performance so that when you go back to
the performance it's actually easier
right so you you are practicing well
when what you're doing at practice is
harder than what you actually do in the
fight in the race in the swimming
contest in the tennis match or what have
you well there's the philosophical
version of that as well when you wrestle
with these really deep complex issues
for which there are no easy answers
think about what that does to your
thinking to your problem solving skills
when you come back to the everyday stuff
of just getting through a day making
decisions about work making decisions
about family questions about who built
the pyramids are so much more elusive
but it expands your mind in a way that
yields benefits with a lot of the
Practical stuff that we can't ignore and
expand your mind because there may not
be an answer and also forming a day
taunt with the fact that you're not
going to have an answer yeah for
everything is one of the ways that we
get comfortable in our discomfort
because I'm a Problem Solver and I want
the answer I want it right there in
front of me but sometimes there just
isn't an answer or if there is an answer
it's an unknowable answer our friend Sam
Harris talks about this right now there
is an a specific integer of the number
of birds that are flying above the
surface of the Earth
but that is completely unknowable by us
yeah and that number changes every
millisecond probably right and but it is
an actual number that could
theoretically be tracked but we will
never know that and you could drive
yourself crazy needing to know that but
part of knowing is also understanding
that you're not going to know everything
let's dive into a question here from
Alex
this is Alex B from Mount Pleasant North
Carolina a fellow patreon subscriber I
love my wife and our soon to be first
born child due in March but there is one
problem my wife works a job in education
that clearly makes her dissatisfied due
to systematic pressures violence in the
classroom and a generally poor work
environment all while earning a below
average salary we've spoken about how
this job makes her feel physically and
emotionally multiple times she
acknowledges that she is open and
willing to find a new job but every time
that I offer my help she reverts back to
not wanting to leave her current
position
the only thing she will communicate is
that she wants to stay at her current
job because she knows what to expect
even though it isn't what she wants she
then proceeds to quietly shut down and
remove herself from the conversation
I have and will continue to be available
when it comes to searching for jobs
applying for positions for her writing
her cover letter and creating her resume
I am willing to help support her in
whatever way I can so she can find joy
and passion in whatever she chooses next
I have a universal problem I brought the
horse to water but it won't drink
I know we can change the people around
us so is it time for me to step back and
be on standby for the day that my wife
potentially changes her mind
so the line that Alex is talking about
here is you can't change the people
around you but you can change the people
around you and when I talk about that
what I'm not advocating Alexis well yeah
it sounds like you just need to leave
your wife in the dust and um surround
yourself with some people who might be
more like-minded obviously we're in a
different predicament here TK I'm really
interested in your thoughts and then
I'll get back to what I would say to him
but what do you have to say to Alex
yeah I would say uh your wife doesn't
suffer from an information problem uh
it's a feasibility problem is is that a
word uh Professor feasibility okay
because the other day I added ility to
something and he was like that's a
needless variant
has been shaken ever since every time I
talk I'm like am I just full of needless
variants
is my whole life a needless variant hey
Sean thanks for this tangent sorry not
bad all right your wife doesn't suffer
from an information problem but rather
it's a feasibility issue meaning that
she doesn't need any more conversation
about what she would be happier doing
about why she doesn't like her current
job that's not the hard part and it
never is when you think about the
changes that we try to make in our lives
you can ask almost anyone and they'll
tell you there's something that they
would like to be doing a little bit
better I like to exercise more I like to
eat healthier I like to spend more time
with my family but the hard question is
always how do I integrate the knowledge
of what I think I should do or the
knowledge of what I want to do into the
particular life that is mine with all of
the unique challenges and the way those
conditions come together to Define my
life that's incredible difficult and you
can't help a person with that by giving
them the pros and cons or giving them
the arguments for why they just ought to
change or by accurately predicting how
unhappy they're going to be in the
future if they stay on the same path you
have to find a way
to help them see a different way forward
that looks feasible for them given the
unique context that is their life and
the challenges that come along with it
so if if she's telling you I want
something different I don't like where I
am but then every time you say all right
let's make it happen she gets
intimidated and shuts down then that
means she's open to the possibility
you're presenting to her but there's
something about the way you're
approaching the conversation around a
game plan or the strategization itself
that just feels overwhelming and so I
would put my attention there and say how
can I break down this process in a way
that allows her to take forward progress
without feeling like it's work without
feeling like it's something that she can
get wrong so here's an example of
something that my wife and I are doing
she's got this box of stuff
and the other night she's like I need
help with this stuff and so we sit down
and she pulls out all these things and
she's like no I got this and she gives
an argument for each thing why why she
must keep it in the box and it's like 20
different things and all of these
arguments are pretty difficult to get
around and I say you know what let's do
this let's put everything back in the
box and let's come back to this tomorrow
and we're gonna do this every night this
week we're going to spend no more than
15 minutes considering one thing in the
Box you're gonna pull one thing out of
the box and each night we're gonna look
at that and we're gonna talk about it
for 15 minutes and then we're going to
make some kind of decision and we had
our first night last night we pulled one
thing out of the box and we got rid of
most of the stuff like 75 of the
elements involved with that one thing we
were able to get rid of it she felt so
much better and I said we're stopping
right there we're ending on a good note
we're coming back tomorrow with the
second thing and that's something that
feels less overwhelming for her so is it
possible to say something like hey look
we're not going to create a game plan we
know where you want to end up who knows
how long it will take what if we just
said one night a week
we're gonna sit down for 15 minutes and
we're just going to talk about what an
alternative might look like and we don't
have to make any commitments or any
decisions and that can get her to commit
to the process of coming back to this
every day or every week until some
progress is made and whether it's that
that I suggested or something else at
the end of the day it's about figuring
out a way to make it feasible what
you're talking about to me and I like to
make this distinction
between help and support and you can try
to drag her in the direction in which
you think she wants to move right and
she may even intellectually want to end
up over there but how good is she going
to feel if you have to drag her all the
way over that's right and if that
happened literally she's going to be
bruised up and scarred and you're going
to be in divorce court really soon in
fact Alex if your wife came to me right
or she called into the show and she was
like hey here's what I'm looking to do I
would tell her you need to leave where
you are as close to immediately as
possible as soon as possible so that
it's not a detriment to your existing
life but it's it is a detriment right
now staying where you are there's a lot
of discontent a lot of stress you're
underpaid you're probably under
appreciated as well and you can show her
those things but forcing her in a
particular direction that's right is not
helpful at all the least helpful person
I know is the helpful man who tries to
help everyone and I'm dragging you
wherever I need you to go go however
what TK is talking about it feels
helpful but what he's talking about is
support hey I'm here for with an
additional perspective I'm here to have
a shoulder to cry on and ear to listen
I'm here if you need me and even if it's
just 15 minutes once a week let's start
there we're going to start somewhere I'm
going to meet you where you are as
opposed to dragging you where I think
you should be immediately because let's
face it Alex it might have taken you a
long time to figure out this whole
simplifying thing this minimalism thing
and I could see how someone would say
what the heck does this question have to
do with minimalism but we're talking
about career clutter here that's right
that's where we spend most of our waking
hours and if you're not doing something
that aligns with your passion something
that you're compelled by something
you're willing to devote yourself to
then most of your waking hours are going
to be stressful they're going to be
filled with anxiety
Alex I'd love to send you a copy of our
first book it's called minimalism live a
meaningful life in that book we talked
about the five different areas of
intentional living and one of them has
to do with cultivating your passion I
think that'll help you and specifically
support your wife and what she's trying
to do as well okay what time is it oh
man it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your questions from Tick
Tock yes indeed you can follow the
minimalist on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalist
now during the lightning round we each
have 60 seconds to answer your questions
with a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims in the show notes
over at the minimalists.com podcast so
you can copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if you'd like looks like
we have a question here from ask your
mom why do those of us who can afford
expensive things very comfortably bother
you so much TK why do you hate rich
people
hahaha
now to be fair this was a response to a
tick tock video we put out there and it
was talking about how quite often the
things that we thought we wanted will
make us miserable right and we did this
whole thing about car payments remember
the car video we did it was a really
popular Tick Tock video just hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of views but
it triggered some people because
they're saying well hey wait a minute I
maybe I have a 1500 car payment or I
have a hundred thousand dollar car and
TK why don't you want me to be happy and
so let's get 60 seconds on the clock for
TK and what would your response be to
ask your mom
minimalism is a creative path for the
bloated not a consolation prize for the
broke if you are someone who is
struggling to make ends meet or you're
suffering through a life in which you
lack the economic resources necessary to
survive and thrive minimalism is not a
message that's here to preach to you
some unsympathetic idea that you ought
to just put on a fake smile and ignore
your legitimate needs and healthy
desires nor is it a philosophy that says
you ought to subjugate your life choices
to someone else's arbitrary opinions
about what you should possess or pursue
minimalism is a way not the way for
those who suffer from the self-diagnosed
condition of consumeristic gluttony
those whose cabinets are full but whose
lives might be devoid of meaning or
those who pursue and possess material
things in a way that compromises their
relationship to the immaterial stuff
that matters most to them that's what
minimalism is it truly is that simple
it's not about being jealous nor is it
about condemning anyone it's simply
about helping people establish a
relationship to stuff that helps them
focus on the stuff that matters as they
Define it
as they Define it as the key
oh oh I was I thought it was at 60.
the ball is still in your hand when the
buzzer hit
it's all good we can't count that shot
it was great but uh we have to actually
in in the name of Integrity delete that
and not not even release that to the
public
not a chance TK I love your ramblings
now
give me 60 seconds I'm going to talk to
ask your mom
the cost of a thing extends well beyond
the price tag and so I don't care what
you own you can have a Prada bag you can
have Gucci shoes you can have a Range
Rover or a Rolls-Royce or a
Mercedes-Benz or a Lexus you can have a
tag your watch or a Rolex you can have a
really fancy suit from Brooks Brothers
you can have any of the accoutrements
that make you look quote unquote
successful right I don't care what you
own in fact if the things that you own
enhance your life I don't want to
deprive you of those things the problem
that I have with consumerism is the LIE
we've been told if I buy more things I
will be complete your things will never
complete you because you are already
complete you were born complete you're
complete now in fact the more things you
get they might actually incomplete you
consumerism is a disease and minimalism
is the antidote
um
nice how long was that professor
it's exactly a minute hey you know what
um since this question came from ask
your Mom it just inspired me I want a
new personal segment call ask your mama
and I want to put on you know Martin
Lawrence the movie big mama big mama's
house put on the Big Mama house outfit
and the wig and people send me questions
and they directed to ask your Mama
I'll tune into the private podcast for
that I'm sure that'll be a segment next
week private as in I'm doing this by
myself without the cameras
we'll check out with the patreon live
stream here in a moment but first real
quick for right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalists so we've got this little
side project it's called minimalism.com
minimalism life is the name of the
project we partnered up with Carl over a
minimalissimo and Alberto at five style
and then the minimalists together in
this side project we bring you the best
of minimalist travel well-being and
design over at minimalism.com we just
released our second book under this
imprint it's the second in I think seven
years at this point and it is called
minimalism Life Volume Two it's 50
essays about minimalism about simple
living from a bunch of different writers
from different backgrounds including our
good friend Professor Sean he has
several essays in that collection I
wrote something for it as well you can
find it over at
minimalism.com book we'll put a link to
that in the show notes as well if you
want to read more about intentional
living about simple living from a bunch
of different perspectives perspectives
that may not always agree with each
other either because there isn't one
kind of minimalism here's the definition
here's the template no it's different
people learning how to live a meaningful
life with less minimalism.com for the
side project over there also once a
month with minimalism life I do a little
side podcast they're like three or four
minutes each I read an essay it's one of
my favorite things that I do yeah very
few people listen to it but I because we
don't ever I don't do much to promote it
but like I just read something and I'll
talk about that essay that I wrote and I
just I experienced great joy and I
listen to those podcast episodes I go
back and it's almost like I'm right
reading
to myself in a way and the podcast helps
me more than it probably helps anyone
else or maybe it'll help you or support
you as well minimalism.com that's our
little side project called minimalism
life let's check in with the patreon
live stream Alabama sure thing we have a
lot of great stuff from the patrons
today do we want to talk about direct
questions or some ideas on how you
connect this thing to not minimalism
we'll get some deeper questions on the
private podcast right now let's do
connecting a few smaller things
beautiful here's one from Georgia
connect this tire rubber
wait what does that even mean how do you
connect that to minimalist what does
tire rubber have to do with minimalism I
don't know it's a dumb question what's
the next one wait wait wait wait no
let's just play with it like like the
rubber out out of which tires are made
yeah I don't know I don't know sure so
I'm not asking you to do the work for me
and tell me what the connection is I'm
just asking like what are you referring
to like are you referring to like like a
the tire on a car
I guess I don't know how does tire
rubber have to do with minimalism yeah
the moment you bring in any physical
possession like that's the easiest
possible thing that you could give us
like this this isn't hard at all like do
you ever need to have your tires changed
yes I had to have mine rotated recently
yeah yeah and so I mean whenever we're
talking about the material possessions
in our life the question is okay I well
here's one for you I moved from Montana
to California in Montana I had two sets
of tires you have to have snow tires
when you live in Montana otherwise
you're running some problems when
there's a lot of snow right and so I let
go of a whole bunch of rubber I sold
them
um and I was able to sell those snow
tires to someone yeah I got the money
because why those things that we're
adding value to my life weren't adding
value to my life at all anymore in
California I didn't need snow tires here
and so I was able to let them go even
though they served a purpose
during the stage of my life a chapter of
my life let's do one more Alabama and
we'll save the rest for the private
podcast here's another one from Taylor
brainstorming what does that have to do
with minimalism
um
that's really good so this is
interesting so I literally just taught a
high school class yesterday and we were
doing a brainstorming session and
everyone was scared and after a couple
of minutes because I'm very comfortable
with the silence I don't feel the need
to like coach them through it we sat
there for a couple of minutes then one
person said something and they said it
like a question right and they they were
like super scared and I said that's
great like let's work with that and we
put that idea down and then everyone
else started chiming in and after we
went through the brainstorming session I
began to talk with them about James
altersher's idea of exercising your idea
muscle and one of the things I said is
if you can learn to be comfortable with
your bad ideas comfortable with throwing
them out there so that you can get
critical feedback and collaboration from
other people who will help you work on
them you will understand the secret to
being able to generate solutions to any
problem but the difficulty with
brainstorming is everybody's telling
themselves a story that if I suggest an
idea that doesn't work
I will be persecuted I will be laughed
at I will never be taken seriously again
brainstorming is one of the most
difficult things for people to do of all
ages I've seen it in corporate training
sessions I've seen it in college
classrooms and High School classrooms
because people haven't learned to
declutter the story they're telling
themselves about how dangerous it is to
ever put an idea out there that isn't
perfect we'll check back in with the
patreon live stream here in a bit but
first Alabama what do you got for us
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners
hi my name is Stephanie I'm in Denver
Colorado I was just calling as a a
person who has a creative hobby that
accumulates a lot of stuff I really love
to crochet so I have lots of yarn and
felt and needles and all sorts of
um all sorts of accoutrement I think is
the word you like with with that Hobby
and I actually had turned it into a
business on Etsy for about a year and
then I decided that that wasn't a good
choice for me well now I have all these
items I have a business size store of
these items and the way I decided to
handle that was to
liquidate my stock by creating donation
items I'm making little crochet photo
props that I'm going to donate to my
local hospital and so it's it's become a
project for me that will both help me
minimize the stock that I have on hand
which are you know yarn is something
that's kind of hard to donate but it's
also given me a way to give back to my
community in a what I hope is a
meaningful way for families that receive
these little items that they can
possibly you know have photos taken of
their children and then maybe donate
themselves so
um I just thought that that was a way
for artists to handle the I have way too
many supplies because it really is a
just for oh excuse me I just in case
item not a just for when when you're
holding on to tons and tons and tons of
craft supplies all right y'all that is
our minimal episode for today we'll see
you on patreon for the full two and a
half hour maximal edition of episode 386
which includes answers to a bunch more
questions questions like how do I let go
of my people pleasing Tendencies how
does minimalism relate to and help
highly sensitive people plus we've got a
million more questions for the
minimalists also this week we have a
private minimalist home tour you can
step inside the pristine living room of
one of our listeners we've got a new ads
suck segment for you probably the most
manipulative had that I've ever seen we
have an outstanding added value segment
a very fun song that has nothing to do
with minimalism and much much more of
less and if you want to hear all that
check out the minimalist private podcast
at patreon.com
the minimalist or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly maximal
episodes play and your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain access to all of
our podcast archives all the way back to
episode zero zero one and if you're
still on the fence here's a testimonial
from one of our lovely patreon
supporters Ryan K says I have been
subscribed to your podcast for quite
some time the public podcast that is and
I didn't think it was possible for your
content to get any better but I was
wrong the private podcast is absolutely
incredible it's almost like an MTV
Unplugged raw version of yourselves BK
comes up with his harmonica and his
acoustic guitar every Tuesday here
just playing Christmas music
yes indeed this is the minimalists
unplugged over at patreon.com slash the
minimalist if you leave here today with
just one message please
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it thank you foreign
every little